watch this guy pack man he's good
Pac-Man he's Pac-Man
incredible I mean that's how can you say
it's Pac-Man that is why I watch
people who think like me
and David Pacman thinks like me and I I
was just curious who this guy is and
where he comes from because I I'm an
admirer of his broadcast this is
fantastic so that this is just a great
thing it's a great thing for the show
you know whatever you think about Howard
Stern as an interviewer absolutely Top
Notch essentially created the medium and
format that allows shows like mine to
exist I know a lot of people talk about
Rush Limbaugh did this and that and the
other thing no no no no no no really the
sort of like Community conversational
uh format that I believe all of these
shows are based on
and the idea that it is something people
would engage with I think Howard Stern
is single-handedly responsible for
creating that so this is a great thing